what is the most common reason that
marriages fail that's a great question
but it's a question that everybody wants
there to be a simple answer like they
want me to say cheating or money or you
know the internet but but the reality is
I think it's a lot of little things it's
this disconnection that would be my
answer the reason marriages failed is
disconnection what causes disconnection
that's the bigger and I think more
important question because like Tom
Wolfe said about bankruptcy it happens
very slowly and then all at once
disconnection happens very slowly and
then all at once so most of the time
what I think people want is an answer
like
cheating but cheating is the big all at
once thing how did we get to the place
where cheating was even something you
were thinking about doing or that you
would think about and then cross the
line from thought into action and that's
I think the the big question so
disconnection would be my answer do you
think it's possible to introspect like
looking backwards for every individual
case where the disconnection began and
how it evolved sure yeah this is such a
multivariate equation
it's it's a it's a dance it's a
chemistry it's a it's what did you do
and what did the other person do and see
that the interesting thing about being a
divorce lawyer is
I'm weaponizing Intimacy in a courtroom
so I'm I'm telling it's full context
storytelling what I do for a living so
what I do is I take my client's story
and I have to present it to a judge and
make my client the hero in every way and
the other side the villain in every way
now I have to be careful not to do that
in a manner that that loses credibility
because even a judge would know even a
judge is smart enough to know that no
one's all good or all bad
but
only if you were reverse engineering a
relationship and saying how did this
break you really have to look at both
people the good and the bad you know
what what each of them did that moved
the dial in these different directions
and I think that that's
um that's very hard for anyone going
through a divorce to do about their own
relationship you know we don't know who
discovered water but it wasn't a fish
like if you're in it I don't think you
see it clearly I think as a divorce
lawyer
whose job is to really drill down on the
facts and figure out what's going on in
this story
I have to look at both sides so I have
to think a lot about my own arguments
but I also have to think about what's
the other lawyer's argument going to be
especially in custody cases so I really
have been forced to look at both sides
for so
many years so deeply in relationships
that once you do that it's very you
realize that the good guy bad guy thing
just doesn't apply I wonder if it's the
little things or a few big things
that caused this connection whether it's
I mean you've talked about granola and
blow jobs but those seem to be stories
that you can can tell to yourself like
um maybe maybe that story should be
explained uh or maybe you don't think
you don't think for an online [__]
is self-explanatory almost I think I
think people can construct a good like
if you ask GPT what do they mean I think
the story that would come up is pretty
good one but you know that's a story you
tell about when you first knew
it's the disconnection has begun is when
you stop putting my by my favorite
granola or when she stopped giving blow
jobs I would say when it's
reached like a critical mass yeah phase
shift because I think it started before
that when she said yeah I used to give
him blow jobs and you know when we were
in our early relationship and then one
day like I just was like oh well you
know we don't have much time like I'll
wait until later and we'll have sex and
then we both enjoy it [__] are
inefficient yeah exactly correct so you
batch it all together yeah so she said
well exactly and they had kids at that
point so I think she really was like Hey
we've gotten certain window yeah so
let's have something we both enjoy so I
don't think she had any negative
intentions there I think that that she
was working in good faith towards the
betterment of the relationship but it
was having this second order effect and
so I
I I really do think that yeah the
[__] granola I mean they're anyone
who's been in a long-term relationship
I guess it's just worth asking the
question
what what does this person do that makes
me feel loved
because I I
think it's very interesting in my own
experience in life
I was remember I had a difficult chapter
with one of my sons my younger son when
he was in his early 20s
and we were having a heartfelt
conversation and I said to him do you do
you know I love you
and he said well yeah of course I do I
said but do you feel my love like do you
feel it you know not just do you know it
intellectually do you feel it
and I remember thinking to myself when
do we feel someone's love right like
what what is it that they do and
sometimes it's the weirdest silliest
things that they would never know they
are the person who's showing us that
they love us and that we're feeling
their love they would never show us
like if you said why why does this
person love you they wouldn't say oh
cause
um I always make sure that when the
paper comes I bring it from the bottom
of the driveway to the door so they
don't have to go out and get it where I
always hold the door for them or I you
know oh I always like again I buy the
granola that I know this person likes
you know or I I remembered that they
don't like it when I put on this
particular record so I don't put it on
like and and those are these yes they're
small things but they're not small
they're kind of everything do you think
it's good to communicate that stuff well
it takes away some of the power of it
right when you point it out
then the person realizes oh okay he
likes this or dislikes this so yes it
becomes a deliberateness to it you know
a conscious
so I understand not pointing that out
when it's a good thing
I think when it's a negative thing like
I I think in in the granola situation
if she had said to him
hey
you used to do this and you've stopped
that feels like something to me like she
she said she didn't say anything about
that just like he probably didn't say
anything about the [__] like I think
if there had been a moment of this is
starting let's talk about it while it's
starting but people wait from what I can
see people wait until the big thing
happens the financial impropriety the
substance use disorder the cheating they
wait for that to happen and then they go
where did we go wrong and the answer is
quite a while ago
with the granola
yeah
yeah so when you notice something like
you notice that little something
talk about it
because that little something is
probably kernel of a deeper truth of
course there is also moods we're all
like a roller coaster of emotion so you
can not bring a granola one day just a
just because you're in this place where
just not nothing is just cynicism
everywhere just anger and so on but it's
a temporary feeling but maybe that
temporary feeling is grounded in some
other deeper current that's actually
building up yeah and I think a good
partner
wants to understand the currents yeah
they're of their part yeah they want to
understand like hey are you going
through something like and look if I'm
the one you need to take it out on
that's okay like I'm a big boy I can
take it you know like if you're hormonal
if you're you know frustrated at work if
you're whatever like we should be able
to you know to to have a little bit of
of that interaction in a relationship
but I I do think
it's so easy to just say to people over
communication is the key but it really
is about
Fearless kinds of communication it's
about really honestly saying to somebody
you know this
this is feels like something to me am I
wrong like this just feels like
something to me and also how that's
presented I mean one of the things I I'm
very
you know I'm very caught up on or or
feel very strongly about
is that we we have been encouraged
culturally to criticize people we're in
long-term relationships with not new
relationships new relationships you put
the person on a pedestal you're allowed
to just oh they're wonderful but every
Trope out there in every form of popular
media is like the wife rolling her eyes
at the husband and the husband being
like Oh there's loaths some Harpy that
castrated me as if like people are just
passive players in their lives and I I
think
that is an incredibly toxic message to
send to people that this is how we
should be relating to our partner like
we should not you don't take the piss
out of your partner in front of people
like the successful relationships I've
seen are where people are just cheering
for their partner where they are
thickest thieves where there is just
this feeling of like man they like each
other like they are they got each
other's back like you wouldn't believe
like man you could take sides against
anybody but take sides against their
partner you're going down like and that
when you see a couple that has that
you just you know they it's that's so
hard to break but but I think that comes
from
having like a
steadfast yeah no I don't do that like I
don't [__] talk my partner yeah like and
you don't [__] talk my partner to me you
know like and that to me is when because
I think we're just so criticized by the
world the world is so full of criticism
we criticize ourselves so harshly that
having a partner who no matter what is
like you've got this I'm With You Like
You [__] okay yeah you screwed up I see
it look I'm not gonna lie to you about
your blind spots you screwed up but you
know what people screw up sometimes you
gotta write to screw up a lot of people
screw up come on get up let's go I know
you have it in you if you have that
person like that I I feel like that's a
that's a superpower to have that effect
on another person yeah one of the things
I love seeing when you look at a couple
and one is talking
uh like in an interview yeah answering a
question especially like intellectual
questions
like uh what do you think about the war
in Ukraine or something and then the
partners talking and the other the other
person is looking at them as if they're
hearing the wisest thing yeah ever like
they're they're looking at them not
waiting for their turn to speak not
thinking about how's the audience going
to take that but they're looking at them
like God damn I'm so lucky yeah to be
with this smart [__] isn't that
but but there's this and they could be
saying the dumbled [__] there's a scene
in the movie True Romance yes because I
love a great movie I mean that Gary
Oldman seems like the greatest scene
ever done in in film you know with
Christian Slater and he but there's a
scene in it where she holds up a sign to
Christian Slater and it says you're so
cool
and I I like man like that's it yeah
that's it like I I've always I think I
said somewhere in the book that you know
you go to weddings and like when the
bride walks in you know everybody's
looking at the bride it's her show you
know everybody turns around is the first
Glimpse everybody gets the bride and I
never look at the bride I always look at
the groom looking at the bride
because there's this like to me that's
every like he has this look like this
because this is the first time he's
seeing her in the dress most of the time
and also he's seeing her like holy [__]
she's coming down the aisle we're
getting married like but this is it and
everyone's looking at her
and and I always look at him because I
always think to myself like like the
look on his face is like that's like
this feeling of like holy yeah wow okay
like that's everyone's looking at her
and she's mine and she's coming up here
and we're getting married and I feel
like yeah like that that kind of
adoration
like I think that's the look we're
describing is like adoration like that
the words coming out of their mouth that
they're like yeah that's mine that one's
mine you know that's such a great thing
like it's such a great feeling seeing
the good stuff like with uh with True
Romance I mean you could uh make fun of
the guys totally cringe wearing Elvis
like essentially being a fake Elvis with
Shades and like what what is he doing
it's like watching these kung fu movies
but from her perspective and from any
perspective you could take on him is
this is the the baddest [__]
who's ever lived like he's willing to do
those things for me but not like
it's almost like an epic heroic figure
yeah and we're living in this Epic
hero story and what does that do to him
though yeah that's what see that that's
the point like if there's a point to
this
to this whole thing this whole couple
thing yeah isn't that it yeah like I
don't I don't understand this idea of
you know we had a successful marriage we
were married for 50 something years we
were miserable for 47 of them but we
hung in there like it this is an
endurance event like the primary
relationship of your life you've decided
you're gonna turn into the the like a
50-mile trail race
like why why would you do that like
congratulations you you took the concept
of monogamy and made it something that
two people are absolutely not gonna
enjoy but you hung in there like
congratulations and I understand there's
religious perspectives that say well
it's a sacred Covenant but I I have a
real chicken or the egg problem with
that yeah because I think it was like
well how do we sell this incredibly
stupid concept that isn't working to
people I know we'll tell them God says
you have to and and we'll sign on for
that I I don't buy it I don't buy it
anymore I really because when you see
a successful marriage
where you see to be even without a
marriage you see a pair bond you see a
couple that really love each other and
cheer for each other in that way and
like hang on each other's words that way
and like are just in each other's Corner
that way
you see the fake [__] instantly yeah
like you you see the difference right
away it's like if you you know the first
time this is the first time I've come to
Austin I've had I thought I'd eaten a
lot of barbecue in my life
I've never had text this barbecue I
landed I went and had barbecue I was
like okay I've never had barbecue before
apparently this is there's a whole
different thing I think it's the same
thing I think it's like once you see
real love like real love and and I mean
romantic love like real love like that
real Bond real you go oh yeah this other
thing's not gonna do it do you think
that's a daily deliberate choice that
that a couple like that makes
because it feels like a very easy to do
deliberate step
like choose to see the brilliant in it
the beautiful in it and almost
immediately everything shifts and it
becomes this momentum or all you see is
the beautiful and all you see is the
brilliant that is a conscious choice I
think approaching life that way is a
conscious Choice approaching any
relationship that way is a conscious
choice I mean looking at
someone who hurts you
or does something hurtful to you
and thinking about what's going on in
their life that they're doing that or
what's happening with them yeah that's a
very conscious choice and I think a
better one a better one than seething in
animosity and letting that eat you alive
but but I I don't know that it's
I don't think it should be so difficult
like with our children with our pets we
don't have this problem like you never
have someone look at their dog
who they've had for eight years and go I
gotta get a new dog like I've had this
one for eight years like I gotta get
like puppies are so cute what am I doing
with this old dog like it's the total
opposite they're like oh my God this is
like my dog this is my dog like the
smell of the dog it's like this my dog's
smell the bad habits of the dog you're
like that's my stupid dog that does
stupid things and it's not like that has
to be a conscious like they wake up
every day and go I should be grateful
for the dog like it's just visceral
that's in them you know and so and your
children like people's children you know
it's why people are like not aware of
how annoying their children are because
they're not annoying to them like I get
it like to you the sound of your kids
shrieking
is like oh my kid's having a good time
and you don't get
that and see when I try to when I hear
that I try to hear it with those ears
like oh that like I'm a parent I get it
my kids are adults now but like I get it
like so when I hear a kid shrieking I
just I'm like ah like to that parent
that's the sound of that kid having a
great time and good like it's so nice
that that's in the world but it so for
me it has to be conscious for that
parent I don't think it has to be
conscious so I I think it would be great
if it didn't have to be a conscious
practice but I wonder if like anything
in meditation or mindfulness
it's a matter of exercising that way of
seeing yeah and then once you've come to
that
it becomes it does itself right like it
it really does like your
I think it's it initially has to be a
conscious practice
and and by the way
it's easier to make it a conscious
practice before it started to fade right
like the I mean that's what's so amazing
about marriage is there's like almost 8
billion people in the world and you're
picking this one so when you marry in
theory
like the stocks at its highest like
you're as crazy about each other as you
could possibly be so that's the time to
get into this mindfulness to get into
this practice not once it's like the
wheels are starting to come off it's
much harder it's like gaining a bunch of
weight and saying okay how am I going to
lose the weight now well I think that
even before marriage like right away
just see everything is beautiful let me
quote BoJack Horseman on this when you
look at someone through Rose Colored
Glasses all the red flags just look like
Flags that's great there's a there's a
certain sense where
if you're from the very beginning of
course you could end up in toxic
relationships that way but
you know life is short you're gonna die
eventually might as well really go all
in on relationships there's a line in
the drugstore cowboy which is great film
where he says we played a game you
couldn't win to the utmost
yeah and I think everything I think life
is a game you can't win and so you play
it to the utmost like to love anything
is insane
because you are accepting that you're
going to lose it
like I I'm a dog person and I and you
you get a dog and you're you've just
resigned yourself to unbelievable pain
because this thing is gonna die in like
10 years maybe 15 if you're lucky
and why would you open your heart to
that why would you let because the joy
is just so wonderful of it the of the of
the ride up until it same thing with us
I mean every marriage every relationship
every love is gonna end it's going to
end in death or divorce so why not like
just go in like go in like go in and
just get get weird you know like don't
Define it the way that's I mean look at
you know again we keep going back to
True Romance but just get weird like
yeah I love this Elvis pretending to be
weirdo I love this like you know like
former sex worker who's like you know
like whatever like just go in like love
this person have them love you don't
worry about what everybody else is doing
in their relationship like we're in such
I mean it's not to me surprising that
that as the performative aspects of Life
on social media increases people's
satisfaction with their relationships
and the divorce rate you know is is
following the same Trend because I I
think everyone's going well what's
everybody else doing you know what how
much sex is everyone else having the
only two people that should worry about
how much sex you're having to the two
people if the two people are happy in
the relationship great then what does it
matter what doesn't matter what
everybody else is doing yeah there
should be an element to Great
relationships and great friendships of
like [__] the world it's US versus us
yeah
it was like when they're when they're
like a unit like that because it's look
it's just us it's just what we want it's
what we like and that's why I I said
like you know even when it comes to sex
or things like that like if you can't be
candid with your partner about whatever
weird [__] you're into or what fantasy
you had in any particular yeah well no
who the hell can you be candid with I
mean because you're gonna either go
without or go elsewhere and neither of
those is a particularly healthy option
or helpful option it's it's the start of
that decline so why why open yourself to
that decline which invariably is just
the path to the chair in front of me in
my office